[Applause]
she's back yet samosas back they've got
to feel so great tonight the hog from
Carrie Anne this is very reviving in
your soul
I needed this and I have to thank Alan
for just the amazing choreography and
dancin say that again that just was able
to showcase me in the best way and for
me to have a lot of things on out there
and it was great to have the positive
reinforcement that I got tonight from
the judges and then some tans honey
but Alan also apologized and you did you
talk to him about it in private because
you get it put it on Instagram so we
don't know if it's real oh yeah we had
lots of talks look I know that Alan is
number one fan and that he is always
going to be supportive of me it just
this microphone scares me I knew it but
I was already just a little bit
vulnerable at that point and I know that
Alan always beans well we're great I
think the best thing is just that we
were able to move forward from that and
grow from that and communicate even
though I knew what he meant it was great
to hear what he meant yeah it was great
great let's talk about Kate going home
this seems banana like your
it's but none but seriously she is
amazing and it's just showing that this
competition like is just getting tougher
and harder to predict and it's just
really important that people continue to
support and that we keep bringing our
a-game yeah I have a question for you we
were watching tonight and we're only
three weeks away with from the finals
and everyone kind the presser was like
what you think Hannah's gonna do after
this because you went from bachelor to
Bachelorette and then it's like a very
easy hop on over to ABC to Dancing with
the Stars so like what is in your soul
like what sex is there a book is there
motivational speaking as their hosting
is there what is it I love all three of
those things and maybe joining the tour
no I have even had time to think about
it no I definitely have and I think that
all of those things like speaking about
my experiences being able to write those
down and process those and then share
them with the world and also I kind of
like holding a microphone and I'm okay
with being in front of the camera all
those things were dreams that I've
always had and so it'll be really nice
to be able to pursue those moving
forward what in what order I don't know
but we're gonna do it you were great on
Entertainment Tonight when you were a
co-host so I think maybe TV at the first
but and you know in the don't I don't I
don't know what it's gonna be like to
not be on TV like gonna be I think way
better for your skin but I think I'm
gonna be like after like I might be like
okay no no no where's my where's my mic
all right talent is anybody there
yeah real non-stop run nuts no brain
[ __ ] Emily non-stop because if I wasn't
on TV I was hiding from people knowing
that you were on it but still like
having interviews and still being on TV
doing other things I don't know what its
gonna be like
I think you should go on a long vacation
probably to the Bahamas where Kevin
Frazier and Rachel Smith are right now
save Hannah beast a fruity drink she
deserves to give this woman a break or
are just honestly anywhere
[Music]